it's been one week since a gunman killed
11 people at the Tree of Life
congregation in Pittsburgh Shabbat
services were held Friday night at a
nearby temple hundreds showed up earlier
in the day for the funeral of 97 year
old rose mallinger the final victim to
be laid to rest it's been a week of
grief for the entire city of Pittsburgh
David beg no spoke to one woman who is
both a survivor of the shooting and a
family member of one of the victims
David good morning Anthony good morning
you know I get to hear the suspects name
today we're not going to show you his
picture either we're focusing on the
victims Carol black hid in a closet with
Barry Weber and Mel wax
she says the gunmen killed wax but
couldn't see her and Werber in the
closet she survived but her brother
Richard was also killed this is their
story it's starting to have a finality
to me that that he's gone and it's it's
a it's a crushing blow tell me about it
my brother was a dentist he met his wife
in dental school and they were just
getting ready to retire he was an avid
reader he was a runner just the most
amazing loving kind funny smart human
being you know everybody loved him what
did his faith mean to him he was very
spiritual and it was very much a part of
his life he eventually talked me into it
to coming back and it's now become a
part of my life too and we've said he
was the heartbeat of the congregation
take me back to Saturday my brother and
Dan Stein another of the people that we
lost were in the kitchen I heard the
first sale I didn't know what that sound
was to me it sounded like somebody had
taken a big metal table and dropped it
on a tile floor we heard another sound
similar but a little bit closer that was
when the rabbi figured out that what was
going on and Barry Werber and I went
into the storage area and I went and hid
behind a metal door that was propped
open Mel who was in the hallway and his
hearing was not very good he opened the
door and peeked out and the gunman was
still in the sanctuary looking for more
people to eliminate and saw him and he
came into the area and shot him and
meltus laid right by our feet and and
died did you see the gunman I did not
see him I saw his shadow could you hear
him he didn't say anything but you could
hear him coming in yes I guess when he
thought he got all of us he moved on to
another part of the building there was
an entrance into the kitchen at the
bottom of the steps
and he heard their voices so he knew
there were people in there and he went
in and shot them one of those people was
my brother I think the time that he
spent shooting them actually is what
gave us the time to escape the room and
to me they're their martyrs they gave us
the time so that we're still here Barry
called 911 Don the phone with him until
the SWAT team came to rescue us and we
were in the back of the patrol car for
probably an hour but we knew what was
going on because the radio was on in the
police cars and you listened to it all
on the radio yeah when did you realize
that your brother had been killed my
heart kept saying well maybe he managed
to escape although really there was
nowhere for him to go he and Dan were
we're trapped they were they were
sitting ducks there was no way they were
gonna survive you know I went to the
court hearing for the gunman I know he
pleaded not guilty when you hope he gets
the death penalty as prosecutors plan to
seek no because I think that's too easy
and I don't want him to have it easy I
want him to spend the rest of his
miserable life locked up because he has
no remorse and I think his only regret
is that he didn't get us all I'm
reminded listening to you that we all
grieve differently some people are
incapable of talking after something
like that
some people find it cathartic to talk
what is this interview for you talking
about it is in the sense cathartic for
me it makes me feel more human and more
alive I'm glad to be alive
she is remarkably composed yeah her
strength was profound
yeah and that she could that she could
lay out all the details in such a calm
fashion as kind of breathtaking and
she's she and she understands exactly
what happened I remember her saying how
do you do Endel down a life of more than
60 years you know in the one interview
the support in that community has been
one of those moments those seeing them
all rally around each other and not just
that community but the Jewish community
around the country and in the world at
least say those those people of
Pittsburgh particularly Squirrel Hill
are some of the most inspiring resilient
people I've ever met on the road you
know and you can just in that one woman
you see it all right there Americans
back to the Emanuel nine and people like
rallying around all of those victims all
right David big note thanks so much for
being with us this morning